What does the random program looked like that killed clang?
Here we have a bunch of preamble stuff at the top and let's get down to the random code.
Okay. Here's the random code. That's all.
And so what you can see is just basically it's just a bunch or random junk.
And so what are we doing here? We're making function calls.
We have a little integer constant.
We have some relational operators and so this is the largest program.
Let's see how big it is. This program is—oh it's not that big.
It's 1600 lines or 37 kilobytes of code.
But right now we don't know what about that program was that caused clang to crash.
All we know is that crashed it so let's just look and make sure that that works.
Okay. Good. So here you can see that clang did indeed die in that input.
We can see that—here we see the assertion failure, unknown live-in to the entry block.
And then the rest of this is just a bunch of sort of other information that clang gives when it crashes.
For example, the stack trace or functions or actually
the functions that we're executing when the compiler crashed.
It's giving us a detailed version of the arguments and some other stuff.
This is all the stuff that we would include in the bug report when I report this bug
to the LLVM developers, which I will do tonight after I finish recording lectures.
So let's see now if we found anything about GCC that's interesting.
And so here we started at LLVM, which includes this assertion string when it crashes.
And GCC includes a different message all the time.
It's an internal compiler error. Okay.
And so what we can see here is that several times GCC responded with a message saying
that it was killed and these do not represent compiler bugs that we're interested in.
These are just performance pathologies where the compiler ran for quite a while on some random input.
And those tend to be hard to report as bugs so we're not going to worry about that.
We can see that there was one internal compiler error where verify SSA failed.
I believe that's a known bug so we're not going to worry about it.
There's a segmentation fault where GCC crashed,
and most often that's due to dereferencing a null pointer.
We're not going to worry about that either.
There's an error in the get loop body that happens to be a known bug.
However, that bug has been reported, and then we have an error here which looks to me to be new.
We have internal compiler error in get initial def for induction
at tree vect and so tree vect means that error was in the loop vectorizer
which is a module of GCC that has been getting quite a bit of development
and quite a bit of attention in recent years.
This is the place where we'd sort of expect to find bugs.
And so I'm not going to go generate program that caused this crash since we already
saw that example for clang but basically what we've seen here how a random testing loop works.
And so if we actually look at the activity on this machine,
we can see that lots of programs are running here involving evaluate program as one
of the driver scripts of the random tester.
Csmith of course is a random test case generator. CC1 and clang are compiler processes.
These compilers are sitting here using all 8 cores on a rather fast
modern machine in order to break compilers.